so isabel was somebody who brought up
her you're saying that we're going to
pay for hey you're not socially
distancing
i told christine to maintain her social
distance was because she's been
traveling
since the pandemic has hit
cody
is in a really bad place mentally and
emotionally because he's having trouble
getting wives to agree with him on what
to do as far as covid and how to handle
it he's having one issue after another
with them and then also
they're not uh working with him on
things so he can't go see them as much
because i'm
sticking to
what it is that he wants to do as far as
kovid
um
i'm seeing him the most he's worried
about
the unity of his family and this is just
just saying that we'll pay whatever the
insurance doesn't pay for
cody and i have been struggling for a
while we're not close it was actually
the place that available and i are in
we're in a terribly awkward place
this is not uh
uh
the experience
of people who are soul mates or people
who even
love and respect each other in a deep
way this is an experience of
of distance
[Applause]
cody and i are not getting better
it's been bad for a long time i would
love it if cody could come for
isabelle's sake
but for me i don't care that he's not
going to be there i think us being
separated for a while for this month
might be good
isabel was saying the other day she
wished you could come
and i said you know he would come if it
wasn't for covid
but hey it's happening now and the
time's right and she's
learning to endure sir
yeah she's fine with it though she gets
it she understands okay she's not
frustrated with it have a good trip
thank you see ya see you
[Music]
i'm just having regret
because the
whole damn situation is breaking my
heart
the whole thing with isabel going and
doing the surgery and the whole thing
with my family and this
disparity in behavior
during kovid
it's really really
really hard on our family
[Music]
you